After a sweet debut in Jessica Jones, Mike
Colter's Luke Cage powers back on to Netflix
with his very own series.
And just like Daredevil and Jessica Jones
before him, Luke Cage's show is bursting with
easter eggs, cameos and references to everything
from Star Wars to Iron Fist, Deadpool, and
a stack of comic books.
I've put together as many of those easter
eggs and call-backs as I could in this video.
Do let me know what other cool ones you spotted!
And just a quick reminder, of course, there
are spoilers ahead!
Luke Cage first appeared in issue 1 of Hero
For Hire, which is describes how his character
operated and is one of his aliases, so it's
not surprising that there are several nods
to that in the Netflix show.
After Luke saves Genghis Connie's from Cottonmouth's
men, Connie says she wants to hire Luke; however,
in contrast to the comics, Luke says he's
not for hire but he will look out for her.
And when Luke tells Fish 'I ain't no hero',
during their conversation in the diner, to
which Fish replies, 'that's a great slogan.
I ain't no hero; pay me!', that's a nice reference
to the fact that in the comics, Luke's heroic
activities were available for a fee.
Method Man also gives a shout-out to Luke's
"Hero For Hire" alias in his rap "Bulletproof
Love".
From issue 17, the "Hero For Hire" comic book
series was titled "Power Man" when Luke decided
he needed a better name.
And there are a number of hints to his Power
Man moniker in the show.
Pop jokingly calls Luke "Power Man" on a couple
of occasions, and when Claire Temple calls
Luke "Macho Man", only to be corrected by
Luke who says his name is "Power Man", she
laughs that that's even cornier.
And there's a nod to the "Ace of Spades" alias
which Luke rejected in the comics when Luke's
told to take up six bottles of Ace of Spades
to the club's VIP area during the first episode.
The silver metal headgear and gauntlets we
see Luke wearing following Dr Burstein's experiment
is a call-back to the character's original
comic-book costume which he donned for many
years following his first appearance in 1972.
And Luke's comic-book headgear gets another
mention later in the show when Luke and Claire
Temple discover a file on Reva's zip-drive
with the title 'Tiara'.
By the way, Tiara was also the production
codename for the Netflix series.
Luke's traditional comic-book look also included
a partially open yellow shirt, blue trousers
and a chain belt, all of which make an appearance
in the show when he grabs a yellow shirt and
a pair of blue jeans from a washing line after
his escape from prison.
When Luke catches sight of his reflection
and comments that his new clothes make him
look like 'a damn fool', it's a nice reference
to the fact that in the comics he also felt
his superhero outfit was 'kinda hokey'.
And just as Luke drops the 70s-style clothes
for more 21st-century appropriate attire in
the show after that, his comic book character
destroyed his traditional costume in 1992
on the cover of the first issue of the new
series Cage.
The T-shirts, jeans, and casual jackets Luke
wears throughout the show reflect his more
modern look in the comic books from the 1990s
onwards.
Luke's hoodie is a nod to 17-year-old Trayvon
Martin, who was shot dead by George Zimmerman
in Florida in 2012.
And showrunner Cheo Coker has said that it
was important to him, 'as the father of two
black sons, to have a black man in a hoodie
and have them not be a threat.'
The colour of Luke's hoodie references his
comic book costumes from his early days through
to more contemporary times as does the blue
tracksuit and yellow bandage worn by the young
Carl Lucas training in a boxing gym during
a flashback scene.
And Luke's red T-shirt in the show is a call-back
to the 90s Cage comics, where Luke dropped
his previous yellow outfit for red.
The Incident, aka The Battle of New York,
and the Avengers get a number of mentions
in the show.
For example, there's a lad selling raw footage
of the Incident on DVD, which he says features
Tony Stark, the 'big blond dude with the hammer',
'the old dude with the shield', and 'the green
monster', in other words Thor, Captain America,
and the Hulk.
Then there's Claire Temple's mother who talks
about the way the world's changed with 'aliens
coming out of the sky', 'people with silver
hammers', and 'green monsters', again referring
to Thor and the Hulk, as well as the Chitauri
invasion.
After being explored most recently in Captain
America: Civil War, as well as Daredevil and
Jessica Jones, the MCU's continuing big debate
about whether superheroes are a good thing
to be supported or whether their powers should
be controlled crops up repeatedly in Luke
Cage.
Early on in the show, Misty Knight and her
partner Scarfe are on opposite sides of the
issue.
Scarfe, who says he saw the Incident up close
and what cops can and can't do, is happy for
people like Cage to clean up the streets.
While Misty believes it's anarchy and that
superheroes have no responsibility or training.
Iron Man 2 villain Justin Hammer appears to
be still in business as we see Hammer Industries
weapons being sold by Cottonmouth, and the
Judas bullet that Diamondback uses against
Luke is said to be based on a prototype by
Hammer and is made from alien metal from the
Incident.
Interestingly, in the Marvel One-Shot All
Hail The King we discovered that Justin Hammer
was incarcerated in Seagate prison, just as
Luke Cage had been, which also links to Reva's
comment in the show about "millionaires hidden
in dungeons" at Seagate.
When Misty Knight injures her arm during the
hostage siege at Harlem's Paradise, it's a
nod to the bionic arm that Tony Stark gave
her in the comics after she lost her own arm
during a bomb attack.
Misty's hairstyle and the red dress she's
wearing in the last shot we see her in the
final episode is a reference to her classic
red costume and look in the comics.
Simone Missick has confirmed Misty Knight
is returning for The Defenders so the show
could be hinting that we might see her suited
up next time and with a possible super-powered
arm.
The Biggie Smalls portrait by Barron Claiborne
that hangs on Cottonmouth's wall is a nod
to Luke Cage showrunner Cheo Coker who wrote
a biography of the Notorious B.I.G. and who
also co-wrote his biopic Notorious.
And in the show's second episode, Faith Evans
who is Biggie's widow also performs the song
Mesmerized at Harlem's Paradise during a discussion
Mariah and Cornell have in front of the portrait.
Marvel opted against giving Cornell "Cottonmouth"
Stokes the sharp fang-like teeth his character
has in the comics, however there's a hint
at that when Pop talks about how Cottonmouth
lost three teeth as a child.
The show's costume designer, Stephanie Maslansky,
said she wanted to reflect Cottonmouth's snake-like
green colours from the comics, which is why
she had Mahershala Ali wear what she calls
a "fantastic, fly-looking green suit" the
first time we see Cornell Stokes.
When Luke Cage calls Diamondback a snake,
it's a nod to the villain's snakeskin-like
costume from the comics.
And in the show, Diamondback's Hammer Tech
costume does resemble the character's comic-book
costume, except for the helmet.
When Diamondback reveals his true relationship
to Luke, with the words "I am your brother",
it calls to mind Darth Vader's reveal "I am
your father" reveal to Luke Skywalker in The
Empire Strikes Back.
Star Wars gets another couple of references
with Pop talking about Jedi mind tricks and
Fish calling Diamondback a pimp Stormtrooper
when he arrives at the barbershop in his Hammer
Tech suit.
And the show continues the tradition of Marvel's
Phase 2 homage to Star Wars limb loss, with
Mabel Stokes severing the finger of a young
lad who's started selling drugs.
Although Willis Stryker, aka Diamondback,
and Carl Lucas were never brothers in the
comics, they were friends.
In both the show and the comics, Willis was
jealous of Carl and framed him for a crime
he didn't commit which led him to Seagate
prison, however, the comics and TV show portray
Willis's jealousy and Carl's crime differently.
Still the name of the Judas bullet which Diamondback
uses against Luke fits this whole idea of
betrayal.
When Diamondback pretends he was responsible
for Reva's death in the show, it's a nod to
the comics where he did accidentally cause
her death after she was caught in mob crossfire
that was targeting Willis.
There's a sneaky easter egg to Timely Comics
on the dumpster labelled Timely Trash behind
Diamondback and Misty Knight in episode 8.
Timely Trash's logo is similar to that of
Timely Comics, which was founded in 1939 and
later became Marvel Comics.
There's a name drop to the supervillain Black
Mariah when Cornell calls his cousin Mariah
Dillard by that name.
Black Mariah was a Luke Cage enemy in the
comics who later became involved in the drug
trade so the name drop could indicate Dillard's
possible future in the Netflix shows.
Many of the scenes at Seagate are rather faithful
to Luke Cage's origin story as told in Hero
for Hire #1.
The sadistic and racist prison guard Albert
Rackham who triggered Luke Cage's superpowers
by deliberately overheating Luke's experimental
chemical bath has a very similar comic book
counterpart called "Billy Bob" Rackham.
In Hero for Hire, Rackham also deliberately
tries to kill Carl Lucas by turning the dial
up on the experiment.
The way Lucas discovers his super strength
after punching the prison wall, and the way
he punches through to escape from Seagate
is also remarkably close to the comic book
pages from Hero for Hire.
A poster behind Reva for a talk by Warden
Stuart is a shout-out to Warden Tyler Stuart
from the comics who moved Rackham down the
ranks to a regular guard at Seagate.
Shades also spent time in Seagate with Luke
Cage and has a similar story in the comics,
later returning to New York to a life of crime.
Interestingly, in the comics Shades also works
against Luke Cage and Iron Fist, but for Ward
Meachum who upgrades Shades' sunglasses to
an optic blasting visor, which is something
we could see in the upcoming Iron Fist show
or The Defenders.
Dr Burstein was also at Seagate conducting
experiments on inmates in both the comics
and show.
In the comics, he experimented with a version
of the super-soldier serum used to create
Captain America and although that's not stated
explicitly in in the show, there is an allusion
to it when Cottonmouth sarcastically asks
Luke if he thinks he's Harlem's Captain America.
And when Dr Burstein later offers Claire Temple
a job working with him, it's a nod to the
time in the comics when Burstein and Claire
worked together at the Storefront Clinic in
New York.
And the end-of-season kiss between Claire
and Luke reflects the fact that Claire Temple
was also been one of Luke Cage's earliest
love interests in the comics.
Like the previous Netflix Marvel shows, Luke
Cage continues to show parallels between Claire
and the comic book character Night Nurse,
for example, during the Harlem's Paradise
hostage situation when Claire fakes having
to leave to get some medicine, one of the
guards says "Escort the night nurse here downstairs".
When Luke accidentally destroys a can of shaving
cream after his prison escape, it's a nod
to the 2-page "Magic Shave" Luke Cage custom
comic ad by Marvel in which Luke accidentally
interrupts a guy who's using "Magic Shave"
cream.
In the ad, Luke accidentally smashes through
the bathroom wall during a fight with the
Absorbing Man and quips he didn't even get
scratched, a good excuse for the shaving guy
to explain how he didn't get scratched either
thanks to "Magic Shave".
We get to hear Luke Cage say his classic catchphrase
from the comics "Sweet Christmas" five times
in the show as well as a young Willis Stryker
telling a young Luke during boxing training
"not to give him that Sweet Christmas shit".
According to comic book writer and Static
Shock creator Dwayne McDuffie, Luke's catchphrase
owes its existence to the fact that Luke Cage
writer Archie Goodwin took inspiration from
the Harlem Detective novels of author Chester
Himes.
And actually, there's a couple of shout-outs
specifically to Chester Himes in the show
both at Pop's Barber Shop and when Luke is
discussing books while being taken back to
prison in the finale.
Another book that makes an appearance in the
show is Walter Mosley's Little Green, which
we see Luke reading at various points.
The hardboiled detective novel is part of
Mosley's Easy Rawlins series and has Easy
waking up after falling into a coma in the
previous book and features the detective's
search for a missing young man.
This parallels Luke Cage's situation in the
show where he's recovered from being shot
in the head in Jessica Jones and is trying
to find Chico.
There's a cool tease for Iron Fist in the
finale when Claire takes the number off a
flyer advertising self-defence and martial
arts training by Sensei Colleen Wing.
Colleen Wing will be one of Danny Rand's allies
in the next Netflix Marvel series Iron Fist
and will be played by Jessica Henwick.
And the upcoming Defenders series gets plenty
more set-up in Luke Cage with references to
Daredevil and Jessica Jones, the other key
members of the group.
In the finale, Claire offers to contact a
really great lawyer she knows, referencing
Matt Murdock, aka Daredevil.
And after Fish finds the missing files that
can prove Luke's innocence, presumably Matt
Murdock will be able to appeal his sentence.
Jessica Jones and how she killed Kilgrave
gets referenced in Mariah Dillard's speech
against super-powered individuals where she
mentions how "that woman over in Hell's Kitchen
snapped a man's neck because he was mind-controlling
her."
And Trish Walker, Jessica Jones's best friend,
makes a little voice cameo in Luke Cage as
we hear her radio show Trish Talk discussing
Luke Cage's activities.
The lawyer who represents Cottonmouth and
VIP hostess Candace is Ben Donovan, who also
acted as Wilson Fisk's lawyer in Season 2
of Daredevil.
His comic book counterpart is "Big" Ben Donovan,
a Harlem-based lawyer who first appeared in
1973 in the Hero for Hire series.
For a time, in the comics, Donovan acted as
a lawyer for both Cage and Claire Temple.
Assistant DA Blake Tower from the second season
of Daredevil also makes a brief cameo when
he arrives to check on the hostage situation
at Harlem's Paradise.
While Stan Lee popped up in police station
posters and pictures in Daredevil and Jessica
Jones, in Luke Cage his face features on a
poster in a local store window.
And right below that poster, there's another
one advertising a Nightclub Party with the
word DJ in big letters, which feels like a
little hint at Lee's cameo as a strip club
DJ or MC in the Deadpool movie.
Method Man makes a cool cameo in the store
scene with two bumbling robbers.
He jokes with Luke Cage who gives a shout-out
to his early work and they swap hoodies.
Later Method Man performs his Luke Cage tribute
rap "Bulletproof Love" on the real-life radio
show Sway's Universe Sway In The Morning.
Interestingly, one of Method Man's aliases
is Johnny Blaze, which is also the name of
one of Marvel's Ghost Rider characters, who
was played on the big screen by superhero
fan Nic Cage, who took his surname from Luke
Cage!
There's numerous nods to the raised fist salute
that is often associated with the Black Panther
Party and the Black Power movement.
There's Luke Cage's raised fist as it punches
out of the rubble of Genghis Connie's in episode
4 and the fist Luke makes while he's being
treated in Burstein's tank of boiling acid
in episode 9.
By the way Black Lives Matter also crops up
in a speech by Mariah Dillard.
The Luke Cage show introduces a new TV news
network WJBP-TV to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and features the news reporter Megan McLaren.
Megan McLaren and WJBP-TV first appeared in
the Thunderbolts comics in 1997.
And finally there's a sneaky easter egg to
the graphic designer of Marvel's Netflix shows,
Zachary Zirlin, whose name appears in a newspaper
headline that Misty Knight scrolls past when
she's trying to find out who Willis Stryker
is in the newspaper archive.
Zirlin's designs are responsible for many
of the visual easter eggs hidden in all of
Marvel's Netflix shows such as New York Bulletin
front pages.
On top of that, the author of the newspaper
article, Jeff Kujan, is the art department
coordinator on all the Marvel Netflix shows
too!
So there are some of my top easter eggs, references
and cameos from Luke Cage, but which were
your favourites and what did I miss?
And what do you think about Luke Cage and
how it compared to Daredevil and Jessica Jones?
Let me know in the comments below!
And if you enjoyed this video, do hit those
like and share buttons, and subscribe if you're
not already.
If you're a fan of comic book TV shows, you
can also check out my Jessica Jones, Daredevil
and Iron Fist videos here, and also 10 Things
You Probably Didn't Know About The Flash.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!